original can make ten copies of the
script for me yes of course I definitely
could at your service mr. Cate you
demand gonna get right to it oh no I'm
so tired I've barely had any time to
sleep from file transfers to prop runs
to making copies there's just so much to
do but I want to do my best
which means never saying no okay pick up
a package yes
okay sync these files yes how was your
weekend yes Rachel
oh I'm just meditating a quick little
meditation to get the old noggin working
Zoom Zoom Steve Jobs Gandhi they all did
it hmm okay I'm gonna need two packs of
water balloons and a can of whipped
cream for my shoot can you pick that up
for me Oh Michelle I can do anything you
wanted me to do I can do this I got me
my fourth cup of coffee can't let my
work BAM
I've been pretty on top of things pretty
darn focused I'm just like kneeling life
you know hey Rachel right what's wrong
I'm pretty worried about Rachel I can
usually sense when something's wrong
what's going on is everything all right
um I'm fine don't you dare lie to me
Rachel jaehun Kane I'm very in tune to
human idiosyncrasies okay okay I've been
skipping a few hours here and there but
it's no biggie I just have a lot to do
for Kane and Jenny whyever you told them
is too much I don't know I just didn't
want to disappoint anyone
well you're disappointing me now by not
putting your health first and foremost
sorry Jeremy it's okay now go home
I'll talk to Kane and Jenny about lining
up your workload just next time tell him
that like it's too much
you're the best Jeremy you're a real
good
I'm totally deeply in love with Rachel